[Music]
in high school many years ago many not
that many i did a um project on the
mexican-american war
with a fellow student shout out to gabby
meredith
i decided to work a different medium i
asked the teacher if i could she she
allowed me to do this i made
i thought of it as a documentary i had a
little camcorder and i filmed
books on the mexican american war the
pictures and i did like my own voice
over to the to the characters in the
book general zachary taylor i would film
him and i said general zachary taylor
and invaded the land south of the rio
grande and i would say and i'd show
zachary taylor and i would say i'm i'm
going to invade the land
and i had difficulty because
one of the central figures like that
probably the central figure on the
mexican side was general santa anna and
that voice now would be seen as very
offensive so i'm not going to do it but
um not the voice isn't offensive you
doing the voice my impression of
general
sorry i just want to clarify yes you're
right you're right he didn't have an
offensive not to my knowledge um but
anyway the central figure on the
american side was gen uh was president
i still can't say i have to hesitate i
have to like wrap myself up for it
because i can't say polk i have a hard
time with o l sounds like wolf and
yolk
you know your tongue darts out past your
teeth when you say pulp
funny james polk you think about it too
much james polk anyway how'd you do well
yeah what grade i didn't do well i i
think i got a d but i think the teacher
was um
furious that i'd kind of made a mockery
of the whole project i didn't mean to i
meant i thought of it as being really
like kind of different and creative and
uh i'm curious to see it i wonder how
bad it is i haven't seen it since i was
in high school
but it was um also by the way check out
that period in american history it's
really devastating and uh interesting
but my take on it was a little bit more
probably inappropriately comedic maybe
she was right well there's always room
for improvement i'm thinking of
improvement oh yeah
should i try to improve the show now
please
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i am
you're always improving or trying to
improve hosts just justin long life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
taking a sip of his coffees our buckles
from his arbuckles coffee cup shout out
yeah well it was a shout out i'm getting
i'm do i want to get more organic with
my shout outs
um
that was pretty organic you just saw
something yeah i just i just said the
name of it um how delicious coffee by
the way sorry i didn't introduce you i
don't know your name christian it is
delicious coffee uh you know someone who
works there i do my friend liz shout out
another shout out yeah i set you up for
a shout out um
and we shouted out president james polk
and uh general zachary taylor he was uh
he was he was a beast he was a beast he
was not a
not a good figure he was like andrew
jackson territory yes and i i'm reading
a book now called the end of the myth i
didn't realize that you had read you
both had to read the end of the myth
yeah oh you're finally reading it
yes it's so good yeah but it's um i mean
it's really about uh well well i don't
want to get into it's quite political
his political ramifications for today
but uh andrew jackson was was a
monstrous figure i didn't realize um and
it's crazy that he's on our build on a
very popular bill in the twenty he
always looks a little wild to me on that
he looks like he still looks wild we
have that twenty dollar bill now more
than when i found out how wild he was i
was like oh that makes sense oh yeah he
he always looked more white you're right
especially when the 20 dollar bills
changed and the pictures became like
bigger and more common
and like bit more graphic like more
realistic it was like whoa he had those
like crazy cheekbones and like but i
always thought of him as more as
different looking because when you'd see
the um you know in school we'd always
have the posters of that we'd always uh
hova maybe i'm thinking of hover can you
think of jay-z and kanye west i've been
watching a lot of that kanye west yes
it's so good but the the presidents in a
row you know it'd be like it'd be like
john quincy adams and john adams and
james mattis and they all had like the
wit the white ways they all look proper
and they all look like they like ate
well and they ate like fatty foods and
were like yeah respected and then then
you get to like andrew jackson it's like
oh [ __ ] yeah what happened oh he was
like a fatigue farrell farrell yeah he
was like huh and then me
and then it was like and back to
uh who was after and then it was like
all those
i i hate saying forgettable presents can
you imagine like it's crazy there's only
been
4 six presidents doesn't it feel like
there's been so many more
yes but but yeah even among those 46
there's no 46 that's not many no and
there's and of those 46 there are so few
that we as a country i would say are
like really familiar with i mean
obviously there are obviously
presidential historians that know about
all tears
yeah but that's what i'm saying like
there's so many that are like oh what
did they do which is crazy we should
know what they all did well that's why
i'm speaking to myself here well i'd
like to read this book about james
garfield because i find him interesting
only because he last he he died so soon
into his presidency he was killed by
we know this because we were into a
musical called assassins that's right
the late great stephen sondheim musical
and charles guiteau
killed garfield um but garfield
apparently was like
had the promise to be an incredible like
transformative president and it was
during the it was during reconstruction
it was during a time that that a strong
leader was really needed and now
garfield is better known as a
curmudgeonly cartoon cat isn't that
amazing yeah isn't that amazing why are
we talking about conventionally cartoon
cats grover cleveland grover's yeah
that's right but good question uh that
you just posed well i'll tell you why
because at the time when i did this
uh james polk
documentary i thought of it as a
documentary because i was so and i was i
was inspired to do so because um i was
really obsessed with ken burns the
documentarian who made at the time the i
think the civil war was the civil war
had just come out but he's gone on
baseball baseball no no i i i wasn't as
into baseball it was baseball came out
later in jazz and i mean he's done so
many incredible documentaries by the way
went to vassar shout out he graduated i
almost called him my alma mater but i
didn't graduate did he graduate yes he
did that's an impressive alone i know i
didn't know he went there
uh yeah wow i think he did oh i think he
did i'm pretty sure he did yeah i think
i did 100
but uh no bomb back no no no no no no i
know you have impressions i know
um uh lisa kudrow anyway meryl streep
come on meryl streep went there yes well
we have andy rooney
well yeah wow here's what i think of
that andy rooney speaking of curmudgeon
he'd be like he's like the garfield of
the human world that's right no john i
don't want to play with od first of all
andy rooney has passed away so this is
right now disrespectful to the rooney
he's a legend he is a legend i know he's
let's get back okay let's be back on
track why you're right why are we so
anyway ken burns ben burns i was
obsessed with documentaries and our
guest today
is
i think our first documentarian our
first official documentarian yeah we may
have had guests who have made
documentaries in the past or been in
them but um this he is one of my
favorites too um i i find his work just
fascinating i've been such a fan of his
for a couple years now um
discovered him probably about five six
years ago and cannot stop watching his
stuff uh i cannot wait for you to hear
him he is the
famed
british documentarian louis theroux
louis theroux the great louis theroux
and what a voice uh both physical and as
a you know his voice in the world his
voice and culture is very important i
think a lot of people
listening a lot of american listeners
might not be
familiar with them they might be saying
louis the who
um but why don't you talk about some
things well before louis was really came
to prominence in the
in the states state side in the early
2000s he did a documentary called louis
um and then and the nazis i think or you
know where he lives among neo-nazis
and it was
it was
kind i mean he is a protege of michael
moore i would say but
what he does that was
i think unique was that he
he had such a
almost benign presence such a likable
um
innocuous presence that he was able to
gain access
to a lot of people on people who lived
on the fringes of society i would say
and he did so because he was so
non-threatening and
accessible and um he ingratiated himself
in the lives of of people who were
you know who aren't often discussed
in the in the mainstream media the
people like neo-nazis people people in
the sex trade people who are addicted to
getting plastic surgery yes
he delves into some really fascinating
and like you said i think fringy kind of
personalities but it's fascinating well
and as he he describes it there are
people with what's what i think draws
him to these people are that despite how
obviously problematic some of them i
mean talking about the neo-nazis it's
like
clearly like um
a despicable ideology but they are
convicted and he's drawn to people
because he's a searcher he's somebody
who and i think i identify with this in
him is that i i have um i don't really
i don't know anything that concretely i
suppose and so that's what that's what
makes it interacting with people who are
so convicted so interesting convicted
about things like the existence of ufos
and or you know or aliens i would say
well i've recently discovered him
through you and i can't stop watching
you and i uh i recommend people checking
his stuff out it's fascinating and i
would like to hear from him now let's do
it can we do that by the way if you do
want to watch it i know roku is like a
way to access shows now um get the bbc
app so a lot of his work is on the bbc
app we talk about some of it's not
available in the states but you can find
it on them online and stuff he also has
a new book out we should mention yes
called
ah
through the rule oh that's right through
the keyhole i thought you knew i didn't
oh i knew you said it like five minutes
ago
um
so thumy
um
so
here he is he does it better than anyone
i think fascinating the great louis
theroux
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again
[Music]
hello
louie hello am i late oh no no i've only
just joined it yeah don't calm down
okay
okay everybody's actually
this is these are i should take i i can
take tips from you um
well louie you've been doing a lot of
these right now podcasts but zooms with
um i've been loving your program on the
bbc where you are catching up you've
gone you're going through your archives
and
catching up with a lot of the your
subjects from the past a lot of the
people you've gotten to know um
so this must be a pretty common thing
for you to be doing i do well and i also
i have some shows going out here in the
uk literally the first
original series of all new material
for four years yeah before it's called
forbidden america so i'm in promotional
mode
um
i don't know whether it's coming out in
the states anytime soon the sales
process is a mystery to me and how you
know how they how they get
distributed but it's been fun
kind of um having a whole new project
to talk about that is actually takes me
back to material and themes and subjects
that i did
back in the early days back in in 1996
when i first started making weird
weekends
i'll just tell you briefly it's a
three-parter
um
forbidden america the first one is about
the far right as it exists online um the
so-called it's self-described the
dissident far right
the second one is about rap and trap
music in florida
and the third one is about the adult
film industry in la in particular how
me too the me too movement is rippling
through
the world about wow so it's great all of
them big meaty subjects right and yes
classic stuff and class and all stuff
that you've touched on in the past i
believe i mean i i've i've seen you talk
to people um from each of that intersect
each of those subjects like uh certainly
the far right and uh the anti-government
movement and the adult film i mean like
these are subjects that you what what
attracts you to these i call them
people in the fringes of society what
have you always been
drawn to people like that i i did hear
you say once that you're drawn to people
who have such strong convictions because
you yourself
have
wandered in life well i
i think what i i've always had a degree
of um anxiety like i i grew up a kind of
a bit of a
worry-prone child
and i remember you know it's hard to
note like we only have our own
brains that we have access to like i
don't know how kind of the inner
landscape of other people is is a
mystery to me in some respects but i
know that i used to worry a lot and and
things like oh when am i when i grow up
am i going to be able to read will i be
able to pay my taxes you know how will i
know how will i you know and ever even
ever since i the the things that
um the un
the unknown things i'd never done before
would cause me a lot of trepidation
anyway one of the ways i would relieve
that not consciously but i think in
hindsight this was the case was by being
around people
who um took me out of myself
often because their views were so
outlandish or because what they were
doing seemed so odd or just because they
seemed so comfortable with themselves
that my sense of irresolution
sort of dissolved and i would just
surrender to you and i used to make you
know i don't know how many people
listening to this school i know my
profile in america is nothing like it is
in the uk and other places but you know
i ever since i went back i was first
hired by michael moore at tv nation oh
it makes sense they're awful truth oh
for tv nation for tv nation yeah the
first ever thing i was it was on nbc it
had been picked up of a pilot he'd done
this was 1994 i was 23 years old
i had no ambition to be on tv i hoped i
might be a
a tv writer i was a journalist working
for spy magazine at that time
and basically
he saw something in me he was like oh
this english guy
you know he's a british guy he was on
the bbc as well he's from michigan oh my
god yeah anyway yeah
apologies to anybody
yeah if he was moving any faster than
molasses that was his wife kathleen used
to well on one occasion said of mike if
he was moving any faster than molasses
which i don't know stayed with me
he was moving quite slowly was the point
she was making
so yeah i didn't see it already anyway
the bbc had picked up the show alongside
nbc and had told michael it would be
great if you hired a british
correspondent
he didn't know any british
correspondents but he knew a couple of
people at spy magazine and they knew me
and i'm half british by default and so
by people are they kind of shepard
shepherded me
in and were like why don't you meet
michael
and see what happens the reason i'm
telling you all of this apart from
anything else this is my origin story as
you can probably see
this is like peter parker is bitten by a
radioactive spider moment those are
always the best those are the best
and so an apology for the slightly
dead-eyed um
kind of rendition because i've obviously
told the story a lot of times but it was
you know so weird in life how one
step that you take you know it would be
nice to think like oh well
whatever you know
whatever's supposed to happen is going
to happen but sometimes extraordinary
things happen
you know i'm not saying like if that you
know by chance more or less or
happenstance right so with
they took me to to see michael and he
he's like
this british guy's got something have
you seen roger and me i was like yeah
i've seen roger me i loved it you know
uh
when can you start kind of thing would
you what would you be willing to do on
this show i can't my microphone sorry
louis what what had he seen had he seen
you do had he read your your stuff in
spy i had done nothing on television i
had done
literally nothing that had been on
television i had written a few articles
of
no great distinction for spy magazine so
you must have seen something in your
demeanor in your account in your
accountants there were two i done one
thing that was vaguely funny for spy
magazine
called rappers discuss gun safety where
i interviewed um
i was a fan and still am a fan of rap i
know i know and so i interviewed rappers
it wasn't even my idea your master p
episode is incredible thank you a
colleague of mine called chris kelly a
canadian comedy writer who now works on
bill maher's show real time with bill
maher
he he said why don't you talk to rappers
about how important gun safety is
and then get them to freestyle a rap
about gun safety
so i did that it was and then i wrote it
up as an article
and
i remember in fact joe the gangster was
the only one who actually did a
creditable
freestyle about gun safety oh really oh
anyway
so i think an endorsement exactly i know
in fact joe he's he's the don uh in fact
i fell in love with i fell in love with
my wife when she was dancing with me to
um
in fact joe and ashanti what's love oh
yes what's love words yes yes
titties is fat but the frame is little
tattoo on on the back
with his name in the middle right i mean
i think he says that are you speaking
about your wife are you quoting i don't
like referring to breasts it's fat it
doesn't feel like a nightmare do you
know what i mean well they are
technically i suppose but yeah
you know you know i never thought about
that in a strictly medical anatomical
sense they are fat so maybe he was
making a like a an observation to
clinical like a medical observation
but your frame is little they're
comprised of fat molecules uh yes and
yeah okay so that
is what would always astound astounded i
was always surprised that someone would
name themselves
with an adjective like that that could
that would could change you know um
he was fat he's and since it's since
lost quite a bit of weight i remember
seeing facho is quite um slim of of a
slim slim jimmy yeah
rappers but yeah look at puff daddy p
diddy prince yeah
they can change the world of rap and rnb
the names of somewhat snoop doggy dog
snoop dogg you can adapt can't you
i'm trying to think yes i suppose there
were a few rappers in the south you were
called lil like little john is still
little john
lil yachty's little yachty but then
there's others who romeo
did you know that's not true that's true
is that's not true
really like little richard yeah little
stevie wonder was a child star in his he
had hits in the in the at least the
early 60s maybe late 50s
but you could hear him he was like
michael jackson he had a hit called
fingertips
oh yeah which was sampled by uh
yeah bruno mars probably somebody's
pharrell i almost said feral
pharaoh man pharrell man can i ask you
something justin just
because i'm aware just a quick on the
michael moore thing just to finish that
off very quickly oh please i'm sorry not
at all so i think he saw you were asking
what did he see in me and part of it i
think was two things there was one that
i came highly recommended by my friends
who vouched for me who are his writers i
think the other part of it is that i was
american enough my dad's american i grew
up with various cultural references like
when something that he felt like well
you know
michael's a real american patriot and
even more specifically he's a kind of
midwestern patriot
he's not that keen on california he's
not very keen on the south really he
really likes if he had it his way he'd
only work with people from the
midwestern states the rust belt yeah
from the rust belt and i think he'd
probably tell working class people from
the rust belt anyway but he for me like
as someone who had some american
connection that that gave me that gave
me a kind of small way in but the bigger
part was i think he just saw that there
was something unlikely about me i think
he saw that i was awkward in a way that
and i was non-threatening i knew i knew
nothing he knew i knew nothing i knew
that i had no experience he knew but he
i think he and what i subconsciously i
think said to him was i'm a [ __ ] and
i know that and basically if you take a
chance on me i'll do whatever you ask
if you want to get me to do make coffee
that's fine whatever you want me to do
i'll do it and um you know i had no
attitude i don't think i might be
kidding myself and i think that appealed
to him well i it i understand why that
would appeal to him it's that
combination of which have become your
real trademarks your honesty and
uh a naivete almost and
and
um
an intellectual curiosity that i think
is such a
unique combination and one that i'm sure
he saw i i understand why he saw
potential in there that's nice to hear
that but the thing i wanted to ask you
justin just parenthetically i am a fan
of your work and i was excited when you
asked me to do this i don't have a huge
profile in the states so i'm just
curious just in sort of market research
mode
how did you come by you obviously have
seen quite a few of my programs and how
did you come to them most of them it's
funny you say that because i think it
was through my ex-girlfriend who is
scottish i almost said was scottish she
remains scottish
she loves you i mean i grew up because
she was a journalism major she was um a
music journalist she's since become uh
quite a talented singer she's in the
band churches uh
oh yeah of course i've seen them they're
a great band
well you should know that lauren is a
huge fan of yours and um
and so i started listening to your
podcast yeah i i started really diving
into your stuff nice to hear that so it
was word of mouth okay good to know it
was what about i know and i know justin
i know
my cousin a little bit and
yeah uh and so you know we've spoken
about you and um
but but to your point i think i i i was
looking for some of your stuff recently
and it is all on the bbc so from our
amir i said our american listeners i
suppose most of our listeners are
american but we from all over the world
we have a bbc channel here and so
all of your stuff i think is on that
bbc's
i bought the the channel and to our
americans it's worth getting the channel
just for your stuff because so much of
it is on there i think
almost all of it a lot of it louie and
the nazis yeah is lillian the nazis on
there no i don't think it's not a
handful of embargo like there are very
few i think there's another one where
the access was so sensitive
um that that it felt like there was
often it's sex themes or
themes
there's one called a place for
pedophiles where i believe it was a
condition of us getting access to the
hospital coalinga which is
in the central valley no it's in the
central valley of
california
um oh a three hour drive are you in l.a
justin
i'm in connecticut at the moment i'll be
in l.a that would be a long time i could
go to them to co linga but yeah but
basically it's never worth it they've
got about a thousand i know maybe 800
uh conv well people who were convicted
of um serious sex crimes often against
children
um and then having completed their
sentences were deemed
too dangerous
uh to be freed and then were sentenced
by two psychiatrists were
diagnosed by two psychiatrists yeah to
be worthy of being locked up on
indefinite medical detention
um and so that one
can't be seen i went spent two weeks
there
um and uh that was one that i couldn't i
think it's hard to see that in the
states there's a couple of others that
are hard to see in the states louis and
the brothel actually how would another
one well how would one get that i mean
are there bootleg i mean god i'd love to
see those i've seen most of your stuff
well i i think you
i think the legal answer would be you
would have to fly to the uk
okay
okay all right well or they or maybe
canada but the
but the internet is a strange place you
know as much as you embargo things uh as
you know work in the film industry that
you know everything's on the internet
yeah
well i came by you i think the first
thing i i saw was um louie and the nazis
and and that made i i according to
lauren it made quite a splash here and
um i i couldn't believe i ended up
because i loved michael moore i loved
the awful truth uh roger and me all
those things you mentioned i um and and
so i couldn't believe it it seemed so
adjacent enough to that um and so well
done that i couldn't believe i hadn't um
come by it but uh
there was something real i rewatched it
um or clips of it on your new show and
uh
there's something uniquely terrifying
about
that moment um
where he questions whether or not you're
a he asks whether or not you're you're a
jew are you a jew that's right it's a
skinhead called skip and i'd made a
decision um early in filming that if i
was asked
whether or not i was jewish i wouldn't
answer now i'm not in fact oh you did
yeah i made a decision i'm not in fact
jewish i just knew there was a
likelihood they'd think i was jewish
and
it was almost a way it was like it was
two things one was a principled stand
not to pander to people who right to
engage in kind of bigotry right like
it's okay i'm not jewish and the second
reason was because i knew it would
infuse the encounters with more conflict
and it was a kind of trolling device
like
i even said to him when i looked at the
rushes later of the material because i'd
forgotten this you know sometimes you
make a documentary and the edited
version almost replaces your memory of
the real events when i looked at the
rushes i saw that before the moment when
he gets all wound up about whether or
not i'm jewish i say to him i said i say
like you know what's so wrong with with
this like me being here i might be
jewish i might not be jewish like what
you know what's the matter with that so
i kind of teased him i i i just put that
idea in his head but and then he's like
yeah yeah yeah you might be he was drunk
at that point
and he started saying are you a jew you
came in here exposed me exposed my
family
expose yourself are you a jesus you seem
kind of greasy
you certainly look jewish i look at him
i can tell he's not a jew he points at
the sound recorders right camera
cameraman swivels around we see james
the lovely sound recorded he said but i
see you
are you a jew and then basically it just
is he is he his wife flanked you the
wife was like yeah i answered the
question i mean they were really
interrogating you but in that example
when you look at it afterwards i thought
i was showing
model composure like modeling kind of
grace under fire but actually i flinch
and i shift in my chair and look
panicked
almost what is it like unconsciously
it's a fight and flight fight or flight
i was like i think you're running away
i'm like what's going on and um and then
she says it's okay we're totally gonna
beat you up we're not like that we're
not like that she's drunk as well she's
like um she's like don't worry we're not
gonna she sees she's like they sort of
laugh and can see that i'm really
uncomfortable and i'm afraid of being
beaten up and then his friend comes over
who's another skinhead who's not drunk
he's like hey take a break come outside
step outside and yeah basically takes
him away and ds to skip yeah yeah you
you also profile a um an anti-government
uh
i forget his name but uh you had
profiled him in the late 90s and you
revisit you visit with him and
that is such a great example and
obviously uh just as relevant sadly his
cause and what he believes in um is just
as relevant he felt like he had an ally
now in the white house and
i i but i love louis with him in
particular and how you humanize these
people who whom others may look at and
and discard immediately uh you you to
the point where you become friends with
some of them i mean you stayed in touch
yeah i stay i've stayed in touch i mean
the i think a lot about that word
friends you know and in because
in some ways it feels like the right
word in in other ways um it doesn't like
in some cases it is and in some it isn't
like i think but there's a friendliness
that exists uh between us and i think a
feeling that
we have many things in common as well as
many things that separate us i think
with mike kane in particular who was
this anti-government
guy who basically was had a bunch of
firearms he was living in a in idaho um
up on a mountaintop more or less
awaiting
the war against the government that he
thought was inevitable he was very prone
to conspiracy theories and thought that
the the government was going to come and
more or less kind of evict him or
declare he was he he had his post it was
classic militia thinking it was post
ruby ridge if you're familiar with that
story post wake up oh right
yeah and
the idea of um
a federal overreach you know felt very
real to these guys
and um and they had a romantic vision of
what it meant to be american that
involved virtually no federal government
really no government much above
county level and you know the idea of
paying taxes to the federal government
they thought was illegal
you know at least more and morally wrong
the idea of having a social security
number a driver's license
was um they thought was more or less
satanic so they joined abandoned
together in these various communities
around the states and the probably the
biggest one certainly the one of the few
sort of planned ones
was in um in idaho under the auspices of
a guy called bogue rights anyway the
your point is well taken which is
20 years later you know um
i'd expected maybe he would be
still either still up there or possibly
in nevada or somewhere laying low he's
now in texas
and fully signed on to the trump
uh train you know what i mean like oh
yeah
and and and it just seems such an
extraordinary
indicator of
how much the world has changed right
he's no longer in some respects
uh marginal or out on a limb in his
thinking right he right he's right there
sort of in line with
these views are now in plain sight and
um and in in a strange way
january 6
was a perfect manifestation of what he'd
always been hoping
might have right well there was that
the anger the dissatisfaction that i
guess disillusionment of that type of
person working class uh
that michael moore in fact was aware
enough of i mean to your point earlier
that he is very much so and in fact
that's a really great um that's a really
great thread to draw together that like
i remember when i was at tv nation in 95
a second year of tv nation when
right after the oklahoma city bombing
and it was around that time that um the
first stories about militias were
appearing i remember reading them i
think like
guys in army fatigues running around
playing iron man
um often in michigan uh it seemed really
odd and i could see what i said like
mike i'd love to go and talk to these
guys and i could see what for michael it
was something different like for me they
looked kind of funny right and a subject
yeah yeah of of um
sort of almost satisfying kids and
whereas michael seemed to see them as
more as
i mean i might be i want to carry i want
to characterize it correctly but the
sense i got was that he saw them as lost
as people who've been betrayed
who who
were absolutely
his kind of broadly defined kinfolk like
working class michiganders right
and so he did a thing where a segment
where he went out and his segment was
called mike's militia where he tried to
recruit them to like a positive militia
and they had to take the oath of mike's
militia which was i'm gonna promote
tolerance and understanding for all
races and they all swore their oath to
mike's militia which is kind of a sweet
and a nice idea
but i think he very much you know
michael moore
he's a really i don't know if you've
ever met him do you know him justin very
briefly no there's through bernie
sanders
not surprisingly he's like he's a very
shrewd guy and he earlier he saw what
trump represented and and he saw how
much
you know well he called the election for
trump
he basically saw how trump would
resonate
in those uh blue collar communities very
much as you said with january 6th it's a
similar phenomenon
[Music]
having trouble sleeping plus cbd can
help a daily use of plus cbd sleep
gummies get you the rest that you need
so you can wake up feeling focused and
refreshed i love these things i travel
with them i take them
whenever i need a little bit of come
down a little bit of chill
they are formulated by a team of medical
experts and doctors plus cbd sleep
gummies taste great they really do it's
a nice treat and they're made with
award-winning cbd combined with
melatonin magnolia bark and lemon balm i
didn't know they had awards for that
stuff but i would love to i'm just
throwing this out there if anyone's
listening from the awards show i would
love to host that award show the cbd
awards all plus cbd products are third
party tested and fully traceable from
seed to shelf so you can be assured
you're getting the highest quality hemp
cbd on those days you just need a
positive push plus cbd is the perfect
go-to product the pure ingredients can
help reduce stress alleviate soreness
and improve your overall sleep plus cbd
is san diego's or santiago's trusted cbd
brand and the number one selling natural
hemp extract in the us
sleep better tonight by visiting plus
cbd oil dot com and enter promo code
long for forty percent off your order
that's code long at plus cbd oil dot com
for forty percent off
sometimes i feel like i just want a
little bit more more hours in the day
more dessert more adventure but i don't
feel that way with best fiends because
best fiends always satisfies my need for
more
more puzzles more me time more fun
best fiends is a mobile puzzle game that
you download and once you download it
you can play it anywhere even without an
internet connection which is great if
you're stuck without wi-fi like if
you're in the middle of the woods you
can still play and you collect tons of
fiends that get powered up as you play
more levels so every win brings you new
challenges and there are literally
thousands of puzzles to play so there's
always more i'm up to level number 105
now which is exciting because that's
pretty far but also it's exciting
because i know that there are so many
more to play i'm not even close to the
end and that's exciting for me and also
there are new in-game events that are
added all the time so with thousands of
levels there's always more to play so go
ahead and let enough is never enough be
your new mantra download best fiends for
free from the app store or google play
plus earn even more with five dollars
worth of in-game rewards when you reach
level five that's friends without the r
best fiends
[Music]
and and it is also something that you've
seemed to possess is uh is a real sense
of compassion and understanding for a
lot of these subjects that you
some of whom again i mean i'm laboring
the point but would be easy to write off
or to dismiss but you seem to really
mind the
human element of a lot of these subjects
in a way that i i don't i i don't see
many people doing all right is that
strategic or have you just been are you
very much not in fact if it's so
instinctive that if anything
the job i have to think hard about at
the moment
really is um
making sure that i manage the tension
between
over-humanizing and under-humanizing if
that makes sense because there's also a
point where you have a responsibility to
hold people to account and and not be
beguiled into failing to see the parts
of what they do
um that are in in certain respects
either dangerous or predatory or is
irresponsible or wrong right you do that
with april the woman whose kids are
april i challenge her she's a nazi it's
fairly straightforward i mean it's it's
not it's actually the part of the job i
in some respects enjoy least like i
enjoy picking people's like thinking
upon just
getting to know them and then
you know on that one we made i think
three trips of filming and after the end
of the second trip
i felt like maybe we were done and i
remember showing it to my exec and he's
like
guys you haven't got it you're like the
film's not here yet because
you haven't really pushed them you
haven't actually
held them to account in a serious sort
of confrontational way
and he said
you know people are going to look to you
as almost like their champion like the
champion of the viewer who's sitting at
home thinking like these guys are
dangerous and you need to dial the
temperature up a bit and he was right so
i had to go back out and we filmed
um three or four more days in which i
went round more or less taking a more
adversarial
approach so where i i i mention it
because you know my default mode
is to be
sort of rather uh non-confrontational
and accommodating yes and that gets you
yes quite a long way but but it doesn't
get you in all cases all the way if that
makes sense it does louis when you then
do have to confront and this is a
strange question but how would you how
do you argue um against something like
it's a crazy sounding question but
with a neo-nazi for example how when you
do have to be a take a more adversarial
approach how do you because people have
so especially now there's so many
different sources and misinformation and
there are ways to
contort history and and
information to support a cause so i
imagine they throw all of that at you
you know you talk to like um or or the
the
black israelites you know who remember
uh well they were fairly easy the black
israelites were kind of or the hebrew
israelites they call themselves
but they are
basically black and
hispanic guys who who
think that they are the lost tribes of
israel and the people we know is
as jewish are kind of fake jews in in
their in their imposters in their world
and i so i did an episode of weird
weekends where i met them among other
people
and they were telling me they were
telling me that um a lot of a lot of
people i don't know what that that
wasn't the right voice i don't know tell
me that was mike that was more money it
was more either i was like you had a
little trump in it a lot of losers out
there a lot of losers yeah
um i have to say for it makes
sorry to derail but it makes sense you
grew up um around a lot of americans and
going back because you most british
people when they attempt i was just
talking to i worked with a british sound
woman and when they attempted an
american accent it's always this
exaggerated oh how are you doing
yeah yeah yeah yes
it's quite you're able to do this
i like doing american people doing
english accents hello mate
how are you
doing that's me that's right that's what
i do or
you're all right there
are you ever
are you having a lovely time
that's my dad doing it my dad's from
boston how are
right he's got a thick well he doesn't
but he's he's slightly deracinated but
his family
how are you yeah oh it was wicked
dangerous like yeah they've got fairly
thick and then someone said that's not a
boston accent that's a working
working-class boston accent like almost
like yes and and and what would be wrong
with that
please
right it's not proper hello
um
but the point being oh yeah so the
hebrew islam sorry sorry hebrew
israelites but the hebrews but they're
like a lot of people you think wouldn't
be um
wouldn't be black they're black i said
like who like tom jones he's black i'm
like well really
william shakespeare and i'm like okay
tom jones i was willing to give you
william shakespeare yes uh and then like
there was another one i can't remember
who the other one was like basically
anyone that you might conceivably aspire
to be like
ludwig van beethoven i don't think it
was but it was along those lines yeah um
yes yeah they were all blank history so
the osmonds daniel
tony osmond would be a good one yeah the
um yeah
the so that's a fairly easy form that's
a kind of form of misinformation
so naked and brazen that you almost
doesn't really require
arguing against right well i remember
but it's tempting i remember the
temptation because those guys used to be
everywhere i mean they were
i don't see them much anymore maybe
because i don't go to his mind dude they
were they've been in the news though
because they were involved in at least
not those guys specifically but hebrew
israelites broadly defined were involved
in at least one or two
serious anti-semitic hate crimes
oh god it got pretty it got pretty heavy
i mean it's a it's a very weird and
rather undercovered
world like for whatever reason there's
very little been written on it that i've
seen
well it which is strange because they
were so visible i remember in the 90s i
think you're a little younger than me
but you would one of the reasons i put
them in the show was like who i used to
pass them in times square
they would have had the santa monica
promenade they would stand there looking
a little like they were auditioning for
an earth wind and fire tribute band
right yes yes it was a little medieval
time yeah with the medieval times
overtones maybe with like phones swords
and headdresses yes and one of those
they were like larpers i think you're
like preach brother and you're like
in the end of days
there will be great success
if you're doing it
the holy father of god will come back
and
like he would sort of do this sort of
like
i mean extraordinary preaching really
but very provocative and directed at
white people
and then basically
um
a lot of it was
most of it was anti-semitic or
homophobic and just
flat out weird
and and then in new york i don't know if
it's the same in santa monica sometimes
passes by would come and
troll them back
oh i would i would try to engage with
them because you know it was a form of i
remember my uncle i had an uncle who was
um
a creationist and and i was always
fascinated by
him and that belief system that you're
believing in the literal literal
interpretation of the creation story and
and um
i i would argue i remember reading
inherit the wind it was just so i it was
the first time i remember thinking like
oh adults can be wrong and and um
they they're not infallible you know
that like an adult can believe this
thing and and to argue it i found really
i guess entertaining and so i remember
engaging with those guys because they
would cherry pick to pick bible verses
to to make their points and and um they
would have those i remember they had
like charts
about how you know that described how
carbon dating is is uh is is
there's a terrific um yeah there's a
terrific book i think it's it's by
edmund goss
who they're written in like victorian
times or maybe edwardian times by a guy
who his father was a contemporary of
darwin he was a distinguished
kind of scientist um biologist
but who was also a creationist and he
had to explain dinosaurs and he had to
explain the rings in trees
and basically
it came
a lot of it revolved around
did adam and eve have belly buttons
right
and it was called his book was called
omphalos his father his father's called
i can't remember his name anyway because
if you weren't born in the womb why
would you have belly buttons and i loved
it the elegance of this solution was
like yes they did have belly buttons
because the heavenly father created in
the same way as the trees in the garden
of eden had rings
they were created with rings right and
he created the world
with almost like a backstory
you know what i mean
like in the condition that it would have
been in
so all the trees had rings
the the the mammals had belly buttons
you know what i mean well it was like
yes if that's fast well that's what i'm
saying the only solution you could if
you had any intelligence about biology
that's the only solution you could come
to right
right which is why my father who was
catholic and and was actually in the
seminary he has he takes a very has a
very like academic approach to
catholicism but he um would say so and
we whenever we would say well how is it
possible that lazarus or jesus himself
rose from the you know it would always i
remember it being well that's
faith there there would always come a
point in a religion i know you're
fascinated by religion and but there
come a point in that element in the
supernatural element of it where it just
it you have to just say
there's there's no explanation you have
to just have faith i mean that's where
faith comes into play which is something
that always fascinating yeah the leap of
fame
but i think also this is actually the
idea that i also think that we tend to
kind of other religion like oh there's
there's crazy people who believe in
religion and then us normal guys you
know i'm not accusing you of doing this
but you know in many respects um
you know we go around with prejudices
and and forms of unexamined belief all
the time and you know i am fascinated by
religion but i'm almost more fascinated
by behavior and that there's you know in
the sense that religion becomes
interesting to me at the point where
it actually sabotages
you or your interaction with your
environment with your family yeah in
some deep ways yes you know if you just
say like i believe in space aliens and
and one day they're going to come and
take us away it's kind of funny but it
doesn't really get you very for me as a
sort of journalistic subject it's not
going to take me very far but if you
said like and they're coming on
thursday and i've sold my house
you know what i mean i'd say right it's
affected your behavior in your world and
in fact in col
so-called cult it's a difficult it's a
word that should have red lights
attached to it but in
the extreme religious movements
um in orange in the study of kind of
extreme social groups i mean another one
i don't know if you've watched you the
ones about nexium the vowel and seduce
this
documentary i just
and you know it's not a religious group
but it is every bit a kind of coercive
social group that has cult-like
qualities and you could say well
what you know what they believe is in
the empowerment of women like that's
super positive
but what they practice is branding and
for sexual subjugation
and um so they say in in the studies of
kind of in that world it's like they say
it's not about what you believe it's
about how you practice and what you do
you know there could be a law firm or
you know what i mean or uh or indeed a
hollywood director whose practices are
more extreme and more cult-like
than
some guy who thinks he's worshiping fire
you know what i mean oh sure sure um
yeah but your point was i'm gonna have
to go in a minute but i don't want to
end it
yes no but i just don't know
your thought which i think was a good
one was to do with how do you argue
against someone
because to argue against racism in a
weird way like people to argue it's
racism
uh especially when they're hiding parts
of it can be quite difficult you know um
and actually it's not like well you're
having sex with someone
you know every day and that must you
know how do you have a relationship with
someone like that's a self-evident
conflict but if like a happy
quote-unquote racist
he's like well i have what it's your
problem with me your problem is with me
like why do you have a problem with me
um preferring my own kind
and then you just have to make a case
for humanism right that we all you have
a right to thrive and that society is
our whole race isn't really
in the big sense shouldn't become
massively important you know only in so
far as
you know prejudice
instills division but in a perfect world
you would really just enjoy people as
people which sounds rather trite and and
but no but you have to i would imagine
you have to distill it to something
that that could sound right but you have
to distill it to something that's simple
because there is um
how else do you argue against how else
do you argue your that cause i mean that
and most of them are smart enough
they're not going to use um because back
in the early days when i did tv nation
you know i'd go and meet a guy from the
ku klux klan and hey mike hello from
texas now i'm doing the generic
british guy doing it but he sounds like
he was he is from texas from corporate
christi texas he's like be careful now
i've been nice like we basically i said
why does your
friend the ku klux klan a grand dragon i
said well so you're in the clan but
isn't the clan of hate group no sir no
sir
so what you just prefer white people yes
there's a civil rights group for white
folks and we don't hate other races i
said are you anti-submitting not at all
that nazi stuff it turns my stomach i
said well why is there a sign that says
this is for some of our roadside sales i
said why does it say for the
discriminating shopper and
discriminating
is in red because it just kind of kind
of looks like that's kind of catchy i
said well but it's is it because you
discriminate no sir we do not
discriminate sir so there's all this
evidence like you know what i mean yeah
we go inside and he's got little clan
figurines and they're doing nazi salutes
and i'm like why is he doing a nazi
salute
it's a roman salute
it's a radar absolutely he's dealing
with this oh man he's doing it with his
left arm yeah they made him wrong
but the point is just that late so it
would sort of there would be clues more
than just evidence everywhere
yeah
far right racist police but nowadays
these guys they don't use for the most
part um they they hide their tracks
right and they they
they're they're smart they've learned
they like they don't tend to use racial
slur i mean to be honest with you a lot
of them do and then you can see them on
the internet but in interactions with me
they're much more guarded than they have
they go i bet um louis i know you have
to go we have a lightning round if
you'll enjoy yeah please that would be
nice just a quick like uh and i do want
to just say to people listening um
whoever because we did a thing on the
tiger king of course that that really
caught fire here uh but your profile of
the exotic pet trade
that you did is is i is my favorite oh
well nice to hear that you mean the one
i did back in 2011.
oh that was 20 years i was wondering
well
not just tigers but chimpanzees was
called america's most dangerous yes but
last year no in fact in 2020 i went back
to see joe
and i i was gonna ask and then i went
also visited howard and carol baskin and
several other people who were in joe's
circle and other people who i'd met
uh at the time and also i revisited i
lived more or less well i spent 10 and a
half days at joe zoo and a lot of i
thought i was going to make a series
about joe exotic and then
i realized that um
it didn't i mean it sounds weird to say
it
you know i realized it didn't have legs
in a series but the thing was he had no
murder for higher case how right you
were and i would i think you'll find
i've been vindicated by events
he didn't have he didn't have a murder
for hire case at that time right he was
saying like but he was he was talking
about he was talking about i'm not going
to do my michael low voice like
i got to lock into a different joe
exotic i can't do the voice the point
being that he wanted even that time he
would i mean it was a little bit like
yeah a little bit like he was like he
was kind of like carol baskin
carol ben she wanted her at that time he
would talk about something's gonna
happen to carol baskin she's on my case
she's taking us too far he had a twitch
one of the weird things i filmed with
him he did have a twitter twitter after
for a week after i came back i found
that i caught his twitch
oh interesting that's interesting kind
of like a bunny i mean the cute version
is a bunny like it's like beatrix pot
you know yeah his nose would twitch up
and down i mean he's a great example of
someone i found we did a follow-up i
could talk about it we did a follow-up
using this material the rushes and i i
found this extraordinary just for people
i'm sorry rushes are dailies rushes are
just sorry yeah sorry no no sorry sorry
the actual the raw material so you have
like 40 50 60 100 hours of rushes quote
which is everything you've shot and then
you edit it into a program or a film
so we dug into that and there was so
much there and there was a scene where i
had my last encounter with him
and he rips off his mic and starts
crying and what was so weird was and i'd
forgotten that because we didn't put it
in the program the original program we
put it in the follow-up program and i go
and he i said please come back joe and
let's finish the interview because i he
goes [ __ ] you
[ __ ] peter [ __ ] carol baskin
yes my animals are happy
yes they love me
yes they happy in their cages so you can
go [ __ ] yourself and he goes off anyway
and then he comes back on camera and and
i and i give him a hug i say are we
friends again joe and i hug him
and it's so extraordinary like when you
see how um
so
how
talk about damage talk about how damaged
he was but also how
much i felt in a sort of weird way his
pain like you that would use your friend
like when do you hug someone you're
interviewing like it's kind of
inappropriate really you know i don't
even think he wanted to be hugged like
when you look at it but you felt like
there's nothing worse than a barely
tolerated hug
uh especially from joe exactly yeah it's
called
joey
it's a 90-minute film called shooting
joe exotic that will be coming out i
think on peacock in a couple of weeks in
a month maybe amazing
wow wow um louis i'm
i'm like so impressed by how you do it
you're so prolific and you also strike
me as they're just glimpses in the last
special there are glimpses of your
family and you you playing with kids and
you just strike me as such a great
family man too so
it's quite a feat to to
um
marry those two uh i don't know how you
do how many kids do you got three boys
i got three boys and lockdown was
difficult very difficult i know uh it
was for a lot of people
much more difficult than me but we found
it being at home and trying to be yeah
do work and be a present father be a
kind of
an available dad was not easy but you
know we're coming out of it touchwood
and
feedback yes yes um well thank you for
doing this louie i know you have to go
there's just a lightning round um oh
also i want
your book just well you know we'll talk
about that on that we do an intro and
outro so there's just so we have a book
coming out in the states called
through the key or which is sort of
about just what we were talking about
it's sort of life it's got the subtitle
is diaries of a locked down documentary
maker and it's really about how i
um
made how i coped during the pandemic
footnote by drinking quite a lot was the
answer
and also how i do my work making these
programs doing a podcast keeping and
then just trying to stay sane in the
troubled world
um i can't wait to read it and um people
should also watch under the knife uh
you sparked that memory with the belly
button comments talking about belly
buttons i just remember him having to
move that woman's belly button it's
really gruesome but you actually get
liposuction people should see
uh vats it's pretty um
you really like it's true gonzo
journalism it's so good life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
lightning round what is your favorite
emoji
oh
your ghost yeah that's a good question
probably the um
it's the it's the uh it's the one where
they kind of
is it yes the grimace almost that's mine
too i often use that it's right it's
like the creature it's
like it's sort of awkward i use it
that's how i use it i use it to suggest
uh oh i should have done this i didn't
do it yeah i like to double up though so
sometimes it will be uh
yeah but that's that's the one the other
one i use a lot is um
it's a kind of i don't know one it's a
sort of oh yes like a pencil is it
glasses or quizzical
oh there's a glass one there's an
ammonite if you if you do an emoji
search i don't know it's not quizzical
it's more of a like
no it's like hmm yeah maybe it's not
with a hand
you're like because it can also mean
like this is suspicious this is
suspicious just like oh wow they're
doing a documentary on the same subject
as we're doing one like a few weeks
later
and
it's someone who used to work for us hmm
yeah
that's the perfect use of
yeah you
yes you don't want to be over
yeah with a claim uh who was your first
celebrity crush louie oh uh
do you know who beatrice dahl is
is that raul dolls no it was if she's a
french actress who is in um a film
called betty blue
uh oh she was so gorgeous but before
that that was when i was about 15 14.
before that there was a dancer on a tv
show in the uk this is when i was five
or six i think i knew i was heterosexual
quite early
i used to watch it my brother makes fun
of me for it when i watched top of the
pops when i was about five years old
there was a dancer who i liked it was
and um they were like there's louie's
favorite and i was like i wasn't there
with my tongue hanging out but there was
one i liked looking at
isn't that interesting yeah there was
there was something more appealing about
this one versus the other i know i felt
that about i remember seeing return of
the jedi for the first time and
i just was so i couldn't i was
mesmerized by carrie fisher and
her next job of the hut i um anyway i
don't want to dig too deep on that and
some of the bondage themes that that
might bring up what is your uh what is
your favorite ice cream flavor oh i like
many of the chocolate based ones
um like belgian you know
like posh chocolate belgian chocolate
rocky road rocky road i like rocky road
yes a lot a little marshmallow um what
is your favorite holiday uh we live in
london and
uh for the last two or three summers
we've even you know when
luckily it was permitted in covid times
we were able to go to
um crete in greece
beautiful island of crete
in southern greece where the weather is
wonderful the food is amazing the people
are great it's not super expensive
amazing it's an amazing place with lots
of history if you
interested in history like going back to
the ancient greeks but also the cretins
the cretans
and then the part of the venetian empire
then part of i think the ottoman empire
and then it was occupied by the nazis
there's so many layers of history wow
how did that become pejorative [ __ ]
you created well it's a different word
and a different spelling
so [ __ ] is ceo we're going to cut that
out
or educate people
i mean yeah
it's a homophone in american english but
not in british english because in
british english we say [ __ ]
for
one meaning a stupid person or actually
it's a medical originally a medical term
unfortunately
the diagnosis is your child is a [ __ ]
oh no are there pills for that
i don't think so that's fine but [ __ ]
is c r e capital c r e
t a n as in he's someone from crete
oh interesting
this uh you you may be interested in
this louis that my doctor friend of mine
said
the most commonly misdiagnosed
malady
in children by their parents is um
micro penis it's it's uh which i the
greek pronunciation is my croppiness but
um
my
sorry micro penis is um because i guess
parents are you know their fathers
usually are worried that diagnosed or
misdiagnosed
misdiagnosed because most of the time
it's as simple as they haven't really
started puberty or
um yes yes most often misdiagnosed and
is now a thing that um
can be corrected i think with
testosterone how interesting i've got so
much to say about right we'll have to
you should do a special i mean you know
intersex
and the idea of ambiguous genitalia yes
is a fascinating area and one which is
kind of increasingly so relevant
recognized and there's i don't know if
you read
much in the way of kind of novels or
literary fiction but the book middlesex
by geoffrey eugenides yeah oh jeff
eugenid's such a good book amazing book
yes um it's one of the few i've read um
what what is an acclaimed movie louis
that you have yet to see that people
maybe shame you for oh i can't believe
you haven't seen almost anything any of
the classics by robert altman like
nashville mccabe and mrs miller i've
seen shortcuts because that was 90s but
the
the works in the sort of 70s and 80s
like there was golden years allegedly me
too you know what i mean people say you
haven't yes mccabe and mrs miller
nashville there's probably one or two
others i saw nashville
too young so it didn't um i i didn't
really absorb it i just remember
thinking it was yeah i said the same
thing
not altman but i saw shampoo
too young
oh i'm aged 26 i mean i was in my
mid-20s i don't know how i could have
been too young i just thought this is so
boring warren b i think i've got a
beauty problem
would you say bt um
yes i
yes the baby rabbit hole that i i want
to go down with beady baby
ned baby i owe ned beatty and that baby
have you worked with warren b
is he a fan of the podcast cut that out
he's a huge listener of the podcast but
what you need to know about me is i love
warren beatty have you seen shampoo
okay good we'll recut that in perfect
what you need to know about me uh what
what if you're gonna remember anything
from this podcast um what what is a game
show pastor present that you you'd like
to be a contestant well
i've been on a few
um as a sort of
celebrity contestant you know i don't
know if they do that in the states so
much but you know it's a special
celebrity edition
yeah
i would like
there's one
i'm trying to think i've been on
pointless this one i've been on weakest
link i've been on
oh weakest link did you was that did you
feel pressure on weakness yeah i thought
i would imagine i
was on i was i didn't give my best
showing
oh that's gotta be i think i would i
think millionaire who wants to be a
millionaire uh
yeah um i think you'd be good at it you
also seem so curious yeah i bet you have
just a wealth of
many different areas of knowledge i'd
like to think that but i don't think
it's the case
well i liked your instinct for example i
mean i was joking about cutting it out
but that that you want to um let's leave
it in let's there's something exciting
about the not knowing of something and
the
chance for uh
you know educating people um
uh do you drink coffee or tea and if so
how do you how do you take it i drink
coffee and tea i've got a
i just finished my coffee in this one
and i've got a tea that i've nearly done
within this one isn't that crazy i'm
holding up like this people in radio
land i'm holding up two monks
um i should have said that instead of
doing it myself yes and in fact
uh you're double fisted i'm steady on
yeah
sorry
did that count as a joke or or the
dublin tundra was too opaque
i think it was i think you've just been
doing so many stories about sex workers
that um
which was either the joker was meant to
be like my penis is so long that i need
two fists but it sounded more like oh
yes i'm giving two separate men hand
jobs at the same time
well i remember
right oh i went to a fisting class
i went to a very
standard uh louis just really i remember
doing it's press for this i did this
movie called tusk and you said you were
very heterosexual and now i'm i'm now
i'm getting confused you know
questioning that yes well anyone who
espouses their own you know you have to
question why they're talking i'm just so
happy the thing you need to know about
me is that i'm not gay yes
yeah if you take anything else from this
conversation just remember
not gay um
uh
if you could learn another language what
would it be
i'd just like to learn french well right
or spanish well
uh anything well but especially french
spanish because i already have a little
of both but not enough to feel confident
of of speaking to someone in a shop do
you know what i mean how after 20 years
trying to speak do i still not feel able
to say uh
uh
okay so i just want some of these chips
over here yes i know you i know
i know i know that feeling where i know
you confidently launch into it and then
bail i just i know i do that in spanish
um and especially in france because i
feel like not to generalize a whole
population but i always get the
impression that they
they sort of frown they do people who do
they would rather speak your language
badly than hear you speak their language
badly which i kind of understand to
stumble through especially if you're a
shopkeeper especially they speak english
fairly well they're like where is it in
space
you know it's easier for both of us
let's not kid ourselves that you're
doing anything but crucifying
the you know the world's greatest tongue
that's that beautiful language what is
your favorite cereal
well uh i was gonna say weetabix
do you have wheat a bit you do they're
hard to find actually in the states but
you can't get them
yes
i've heard of them uh yes we have a
shredded wheat is a big thing these are
slightly different the weetabix you can
when i when i've been living in la
there's uh ralph's
on weston and and um in sunset no
western and hollywood
and um yes you can get them there for
some reason
okay huh i'm going to check them out i'm
going to send you put a little milk on
them a little bit of sugar or honey and
i don't eat a lot of cereal
i don't
anyway i probably i don't eat breakfast
at the moment regularly because i'm just
someone said like if you
i'm gonna be you know you shouldn't
really talk about
tips for like keeping your weight down
apparently because it's sort of yeah
i've been warned that that's can trigger
people to like i'm going to do that
i don't know am i worried about that too
much
maybe well
everyone should eat a balanced diet of
three meals
except me
did your sp
speaking of did your liposuction areas
come back i mean did you keep that
weight off it was a um
i remember watching that and thinking i
have the same thing
i think it did help a little bit i don't
really know because at the beginning of
lockdown i started doing these daily
online uh workouts like i would look at
there was a fitness guru in the uk
called joe wicks who did these live
workout sessions and i just began doing
those and i still do them every morning
and i'm managing to stay trim
uh thanks to that yeah i think it sort
of does help a bit um
yeah the the lipo i don't think it hurts
well it hurts a bit when you're doing um
if you
if you
if you i'm not he's like cleaning me
from the inside uh if you had to choose
a different first name louis what would
what would it be
uh i think it's a pretty cool
name is i
i i'm torn between like just taking my
middle name which would be kind of
convenient sebastian sebastian theroux
oh
that's that sounds okay doesn't it i
mean i'm tempted to say something kind
of weird like there's a name in croatia
which is darko
d-a-r-k-o which i've always
um i think i'd have to go sebastian well
if you had a sandwich uh named after you
that the louis theroux um what would be
on it what would it be uh there's a
place in l.a in hollywood called sabori
kultura where i i wrote a lot of my a
book i wrote in 2018
called uh gotta get through this and
they have a sandwich in there uh yeah
it's a it's a toasted sandwich it's got
little mayonnaise
some uh cheese
pepper
tomato like it's got a few different
it's like a basically it's a cheese and
vegetable sandwich was so delicious and
i would be so honored if they would call
it after me
and um i survived on those when i was
writing in there because i didn't have
an office i would just go in there and
tap away on my laptop
what is your favorite tom hanks movie
louie
oh probably you know the one that's
springing to mind is castaway
really when i saw it it's got that
feeling of um you know it feels fairly
light you know when you're watching it
and then it gets darker and then it's
actually
quite a layered film isn't it yes yes it
is and like a real examination
of uh like you know the true human
the human condition on on someone on
their own for that long uh i i love that
movie and what's amazing about his
performance is that he just as an actor
that he's able to hold
one amazing
yeah well and the volleyball well i feel
like you're slightly
ignoring how much the volleyball did
right
that's true wilson is uh who played
wilson again well
as i understand it was an actual not a
professional actor right which
no well really
a first time but playing but sometimes
they say playing yourself is harder
gabriel byrne says and introducing
wilson
as wilson i guess um
would you rather would you rather take a
time machine to the past or the future
oh that's a really interesting question
and if the past is there a particular
period you'd like to you'd like to walk
around in i think i'd rather go to the
past yeah i think the future might just
be depressing right and confusing and
and also you wouldn't have that that
you'd be like it'd be like coming out of
prison be like how do i work my phone
they'd be like that's not a phone
right i'd say
that's my wife
that's my best day i'd put her down yeah
you're fingering
so i think the past you'd be less liable
there'd be faux pas with the culture why
does she have buttons i'm gonna cancel
you for saying that about my wife uh
immediately i don't you'll be able to
cancel people like that you
i'd like to go into the past because in
the past you could lord it over and
they'd be like um
yeah they'd be saying things like
how do you know all that we need to rub
these sticks together be like
stand aside
i've got a friend called zippo you know
you would be able to all well they just
say ignorant things and you'd laugh at
them
although how much you'd be able to you'd
have to bring a little kit bag with you
wouldn't you oh i thought you were going
to say a friend because you'd be on your
own i mean to laugh it'd be hard to
really appreciate funny at all
yeah it'd be probably pretty well the
classic is you would be like nick cage
and like invent all the beatles songs
you know in peggy sue got married yes
well uh are you uh are you more of a
night or morning person louie
uh morning yes okay and uh beecher
mountains do you prefer
i'd probably say mountains do you have a
preference to toilet roll over or being
under over over so it's coming yes you
it's like presenting yes it's rippable
side to you easy to
agree and if you would our last thing if
you would finish this sentence uh louie
life is short so
go
go and have a little bit of fun listen
to some music and hold those closest to
you
uh
dear
i'm losing the thread and the main thing
is is that conflict and you know the
people that we
love the best are often the ones we hurt
the most
but that's the name love is expressed in
in surprising ways right and that love
isn't the opposite yeah the opposite of
love isn't hate it's indifference and
and so
and so you know ian foster said it best
when he said only connect
only connect i love that and there's a
lumineer song that that is there's a
line the opposite of love is
indifference i would have yes i well
said um
uh a classic uh louis through ending uh
thank you for uh tying it all up in such
a beautiful ways only you could and
thank you for doing this louis i i
really oh pleasure thanks justin take
care enjoy the rest of your day cheers
thank you louie
[Music]
so that so that
so that just that just happened so that
just happened that just happened it's a
bit more is it like this
it's um i don't know i mean it's pretty
like it's pretty uh i don't want to say
down the down the middle yeah
right it's um yes it's a bit it's
inquisitive it's got i don't know it's
hard for me to separate the voice now
from
the work i've seen him do yes because to
me he is such a
kind of like inquisitive person that
it's hard for me not to imbue an
impression with that inquisitive nature
you know he's but i don't understand why
but
why would you do that could it be in
fact that you want i love when he
presents things like that to people
what would you say to people who might
think that what you're doing
is a bit dangerous
but yeah unhealthy
you know yeah it's interesting that he
he's got this quality about him that is
that allows him to mix in with these
extreme people yeah that's
i think the simplest way to put it is
that he's extremely
maybe like the most non-judgmental yeah
person i've ever seen on like
interviewing so well that's why i asked
him like is that an you know it doesn't
seem like an act and so i hope that
wasn't an inherently insulting question
i hope the question didn't imply that it
it could be an act no i know i don't
think he i don't think he saw it that
way but the way he explained it was
he said it's it's not deliberate if
anything it's
it's something quite different it's he
tries to to consciously be
non-confrontational yeah um
oh man speaking of but that comes off
it's interesting like how those two
things compare to each other you know
non-confrontational and non-judgmental
are very similar in a way because i
think when people are
being asked questions
if they're being asked them in a way
that's
non-confrontational like kind of laid
back
and
not hostile yeah that'll come off as
non-judgmental that's true and that's
how it comes off with him yeah um the
rap talk was funny the rapture oh yeah
god rap white do i say rap chat the
hip-hop chatter
yeah um that is funny that
that little romeo and fat joe are but i
guess he's right those names are fluid
like they do often change their names
but yeah the ones that refer
in like an adjectival way
to people they don't change their names
right like um except for little romeo
dropped a lil yeah he did and little bow
wow did too i think but fat joe there's
no fat joe wouldn't be like
slightly overweight joe
like snoop doggy dog changing to snoop
dogg he could be joe it's like
that's the same balls
or like puff daddy see puff daddy like
did it like gradually where he went did
he do a wild one oh diddy dirty money it
was like i thought diddy dirty money was
the name of a group
oh maybe i thought you told me to change
the ditty dirty money i think didn't he
i think we're each other's sources when
it comes to this stuff yeah
huge mistake well adam palik told me the
other day future guest i know i'm not
supposed to do that
i just leaned into it i got like no i
was like
like grab it
that's the mom move
but he said um he loves kanye west he
but he i he said that he kanye
he laughed when i said didn't you think
it was yi
and he goes
now i will talk about it when he's on oh
yeah i can't wait
but he has a new one called i think he's
jesus now
oh i've heard i've seen that jesus i
thought it was jesus
i thought it was jesus yes
yes
uh yeah yeah yeah speaking of
pronunciation why is
what were you gonna say about uh fat joe
um and little romeo
i i just think it's interesting that
they're the ones who don't oh yeah they
don't change they don't alter their
names based on their conditions whereas
kanye and snoop oh yeah p diddy they all
change their names but but it's not
specific to the changes they've made in
their lives right yeah but maybe like if
fat joe again if fat joe lost a bunch of
weight he's still fat joe yes but little
romeo joe did lose weight little romeo
grew up and now he's an adult and i was
just romeo but yeah
he's still kind of small he could still
be a little roman that's true the lil
was about but he's gone through puberty
he's post-pubescent romeo but all the
lil rappers like lil wayne lil yachty i
don't think it refers to their son
it's not little lil nas little nazix
he's an adult i know but but
they're an adult what i'm saying what
i'm saying is i don't think
that's a reference to their size um you
know
yes like i don't think little but lil
wayne is small lil wayne is small like
really small yeah really lil is little
john small
i don't think so i think a little john
who's the one who was like yes yeah hey
what'd he say yeah
what he was his catchphrase it was one
word i think and he drank that um
scissorp drink
he i don't know i think he had like a
scissor problem little that's little
john who was a scissor yeah
uh it's it's a combination of like it's
cough syrup you don't remember this they
were
some certain rap artists in the hip-hop
artists were mixing and other people and
classically trained musicians i'm sure
did this
they mixed um
cough syrup with like soda or some sort
of alcohol costume sounds familiar
scissor
scissor
scissor an intoxicating beverage made by
adding coughs here intoxicating
made by it gets naughty yes cough syrup
containing codeine and and promethazine
to a carbonated soft drink oh oh so it's
just a soft drink that's more innocent
than i thought i mean the coating is
heavy duty i contend for the record that
rappers who have the lil in front of
their names yeah and there's a number of
them
i i contend that it's not because
of their stature
their physical stature i don't think
that's why they pick lil oh you oh
really i don't think so no i know in
fact if anything it would be
but it's a bold move but i don't
know why they do it
lil yeah this is little
well that explains it
it's yeah yeah
yeah oh i remember that yeah is that a
little john
that's little john lil john's yeah was
like
yeah and crunk was the that was the sub
genre i feel like in the last few weeks
this podcast has become boomer the most
white
show podcast
among all podcasts maybe
maybe maybe
yeah um but you know i mean we're trying
to figure it out we are and and during
that time i just hadn't got i'm by the
way
kanye i mean like now i'm like listening
to kanye's whole catalog he's really
he's a genius speaking of justin thoreau
is his cousin yeah but he's louis
theroux i wonder why they pronounce
their names differently
okay well so i was
are you setting me up for this i was
supposed to ask him and i don't know why
i didn't i was cure i was curious about
that myself and so
i texted louie that question i said uh
forgot to ask you this why do you
pronounce your last names differently
and he said yes good question
this is a funny response he said yes
good question he's definitely wrong btw
[Laughter]
that's funny i said hahaha that's it i'm
through with him
hopefully future guest and you can ask
justin throw to i'm going to what he
thinks i asked justin i think i texted
justin as soon as why it just was
supposed to do the show like a year i
had to text him about the show he was
already yeah he was all into doing it
sam reached out said justin what's it
and now i'm texting him i'm not getting
a response and then i told i said uh i
even said like your cousin's coming on
and nothing so i'm i'm hoping he changed
his number or
he i did something to cause him offense
i would guess the former i hope so i
like justin a lot we've always had fun
together funny when you asked justin's i
always take a shine to like a jet you
know you like bieber
um i do i
huh you
had a little bieber in my belly um i uh
i i do i think justin bieber is yes i do
like him he's talented i think he's
evolved quite a bit from when you know i
was talking to somebody about this the
other day like that before a musician
about this like who came of age and was
a rock star during the non-phone
time you know before like everyone had a
cell phone and he said
if there had been phones everywhere like
i i would never have been able to make
the mistakes i made and learn from those
mistakes and grown from them and so
i don't know i don't envy somebody who
is like as famous as justin bieber was
at that young age having to like go
through that in the public i mean boohoo
i know but like
i don't know i i kind of like like he
found god he believes in this thing and
he's he'd marry he seems like he's
good for him he's a talented guy well
hopefully future friend of the show
maybe that's why i'm maybe
buttering him up you asked louie
um and we like the same sushi restaurant
you said when did when did creighton
become pejorative and he was like but
and i thought it was such a perfect
response because he basically said
he could have made you feel like an
idiot i know because it was it's an
entirely different word
and
no but it it speaks to how
non-judgmental and you're right
comfortable he makes people feel yes
that he corrected you in such a
such a kind easy way
yeah without like a whiff of judgment i
know i know that's hard to do yeah did
you i couldn't do that do you ever find
yourself when somebody mispronounces a
word if you like them you want them to
know how to say it properly well if you
don't like them you wouldn't correct
them in the phrase that's true that is
true unless you were some school mom who
like yeah couldn't help himself unless
you really didn't like them and you were
like uh
did you mean he and i yeah i know i know
i know or or like an english teacher i
mean we're from a family of two english
teachers true two of the five people in
our family are english teachers or where
my mother was true that and so um and
our father has a great respect for the
english language and so
we got a fair amount of that i still
think about that sometimes i feel like i
whenever i do get the
you know eye and you feel me confused i
i take a moment to like just double
check in my brain because it's scary to
say wrong i do feel
yeah yeah which you know a little bit of
shame like i'm i'm grateful for because
i i now kind of
do know for the most part the difference
i don't know the difference obviously
between [ __ ] and [ __ ] and uh people
from creed
or the difference between lil john and
lil yachty i'm less embarrassed about
that okay
lil nosex though um because isn't there
a little nause not to
this this little conversation has become
there's a diminutive
that's who he's that's his full name
yeah that's his fault that's his birth
certificate
oh you had a funny one uh
asap rocky's
full name was as soon as possible
rockingford
i i don't remember if i tweeted i think
i may have i think i may have been so
proud of that that i tweeted that which
is so rare i don't tweet oh really i
think i did as soon as possible
rockingford
um let's let's read a letter okay here
we go
from lauren c
subject hi boys my name is lauren i'm 24
years old and i've recently been
diagnosed
diagnosed with lung cancer
oh my god
i have never smoked a day in my life
nor am i exposed to any harmful gases
that we know of we've tested for radon
and such i'm writing to you in hopes of
bringing awareness to those with lung
cancer oh my god
never smoked a day lung cancer what the
[ __ ] how does that that's so unfair
um
i'm so sorry to hear that lauren uh back
to your letter more and more research
are finding that young white women are
being diagnosed with lung cancer with no
knowledge of why huh at 24 years old i'm
realizing that life is short and that's
that i've already let too many
opportunities pass me by
not to bring the mood down anymore but
my twin sister we was diagnosed with
anorexia when we were 15 dropping to 70
pounds at five foot nine in high school
i remember saying goodbye to her five
times god
luckily ten years later she's still with
us good
needless to say it's been a fun decade
oh man
um please help spread the awareness that
cancer and eating disorders as well as
other illnesses even covet has no bias
no prejudice does not discriminate on
age or race it can happen to anyone i
it's a very good point and thank you for
bringing that awareness to us because i
i thought that way about lung cancer i
mean wouldn't you think lime cat
yeah i just assume it's a smoker
somebody's older i mean [ __ ] keith
richards i like every time i've seen
that guy he's got a cigarette in his
mouth and he's he's okay
and this girl 24 years old
i mean not that i wish any illness
yeah yeah keith richards um
and back to lauren uh i love the podcast
and you guys make me laugh and give me a
friendly comfort for my car rides to
treatment oh man well we're obviously
rooting for you and lauren and thank you
for
the kind words and um
man i i we'd love to hear
how your progress is going um i i we're
wishing you the best
uh oh and she says thank you and best
lauren from north uh north nh uh
yeah new hampshire but north why why was
that in my head i don't know
p.s i love you
p.s i love you ah i had to throw in a
beatles reference yes p.s i love you
sorry i had to do it uh pss i thought it
was pps
uh pss i said pps
yeah
is this your gentle way of correcting
lauren maybe but but i thought it was no
is that no it wasn't it wasn't i swear
it wasn't because i think um she might
be right i'm i'm not that convicted
about it being pps you know ps stands
for i don't post script okay post script
so i think it would be post post script
not post script script okay so you are
correcting lauren i guess so pss would
you rather shed
like a snake ever oh good it's a would
you rather would you rather shed like a
snake every month or molt hard one oh
well oh
molt ol sounds you should know better
lauren
uh or molt your hair like a bird but
never knowing what color your new hair
would be huh oh i think i would like
that oh i didn't know birds that's what
molting means see i'm learning something
from lauren as she oh maybe if she's
listening learn the pps thing um i mult
it means you like a bird shedding and
bird yeah they're feathers feathers
changing yeah oh yeah molting you know
maybe i did know that i mean i know it's
it's it would be wild if like the next
time you saw me i'd like little pink
fuzzy hair
but um
i think that would be kind of a fun way
to live
it would always be surprising like i
wonder what my hair is going to look
like next and and if you hated it you
wear a hat whereas if you're shedding
your skin now i know it'd be a little
harder to hide that crazy eczema we're
like what's wrong yeah i thought i would
definitely pick it i saw dry skin
convert you know when you watch like
jeopardy or wheel of fortune it's like
it's all pharmaceutical commercials that
sell like
um you know centrum silver or
you have a problem with your osteo
[Music]
what something yeah um and and there was
one about dry skin remember did you see
that one and then yes
but also the thing about having like
cool colored hair is it's different from
when we i still have this like
old-fashioned now instinct that is like
oh i don't want to be like seen i don't
want to be like they call attention to
myself peacocking peacocking and like
because when we were growing up it was
you know you very rarely would you see
someone they'd be like punks you'd if
you saw someone with like fuchsia
colored hair like bright [ __ ] green
whatever
or you know whatever color neon orange
it would be everyone would look and it
would be rare to see but now i just saw
somebody i thought this the other day
this this grocery store i saw somebody
with green hair just walking around hey
how you doing mike and that
congresswoman has that bright purple
hair oh that's right what's her name
rosa de laura yes good yeah she pointed
out the other day i know you see it all
the time now it's so you know in in when
i was in um bulgaria it was everywhere
uh people had
older women too had like really like you
know colorful hair so
i don't think so you'd pick that one for
sure
for sure and i think you're right i
think it'd be kind of like fun like oh
what's what what does nature have in
store for you exactly this month um good
question a quick question yeah thank you
lauren and and again like um write back
in and please let us know how you're
doing we're pulling for you pulling for
you lauren's scene in new hampshire and
if you guys would like your sis and yeah
if you guys would like to write in like
lauren did our email address is life is
short at wondering.com and um thank you
to lauren and to the brilliant
fascinating yeah very charming louis
through check out his book theroux i
also like how oh sorry
no wow that's rare for me to like yeah
business yeah no sorry go ahead too late
no no no lightning strikes once
no that's not the expression it's light
you can only yeah lightning only strikes
the same place you only live once you
only live once you know we had a
remember the math teacher we had a math
teacher who was struck by lightning
twice that's true shout out ms bowen yes
uh so it's
yeah it's his book is uh through the
keyhole that's right and um check out
his stuff yeah all of his stuff
fascinating download the bbc app uh not
a sponsor but it's worth getting just to
like
we got it just to watch his stuff he is
so i mean he's he's so prolific um
so thank you we really thank him for
also lending a little bit of class to
this show i thought he was a classy
guest lord knows we needed it anyway
thank you louie and um
thanks to all the thorus and the
thoreau's and justin if you're listening
come on text me back thanks to justin
back
uh we'll talk to you next week
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long and it is also produced
by katie b allen and megan v monaco
senior producer on this one and everyone
actually is michelle miesha lands and
the audio engineer is
sergio enriquez we got executive
producer marshall louie for
wondering bye everyone thank you so much
for listening thank you louie
[Music]
yeah
yeah fanny
yeah that's what brett's called the
vaginas yeah
it is yeah
you didn't know this
i lived in england and i said oh you're
wearing like a fanny pack and they're
like
what they were all like disgusting now
that's something new no no it is because
no fanny has always been
no that's something you've never had
yeah they've been saying fanny for a
long time 20 years ago
oh and they announced something bad
that's a shame why is that machine no it
makes it better yeah which is more
useful
but vaginas are great
yeah it's not it's not the truth
it's not like you're a [ __ ]
you know what it means in latin vegeta
wait
what it's a sheath
oh okay oh that makes sense
that's pretty uh
that's pretty misogynistic to call it
that it is the whole penis like a sword
is it does it sound like a sword
excalibur where did vagina come from
you